look what they're offering us now
they're their answer is okay we've
removed God from the equation and what
do we get we get government and they
they now pray basically to government
[Music]
[Applause]
that is a great welcome thank you so
much well welcome to tonight's big
conversation filmed live here in Costa
Mesa California
the big conversation is produced by
premier Christian radio in partnership
with the Templeton religion trust and
it's a series of video discussions
between thinkers across the religious
spectrum looking at some of the biggest
questions in life who are we what's it
all about
looking at science faith philosophy what
it means to be human
I'm delighted to say that certain
tonight we're going to be sitting down
and hearing from two people that I've
really been looking forward to bringing
into conversation together we're going
to be looking at the question of is God
dead it's a conversation on faith
culture and the modern world where are
the next generation turning to in an
increasingly Pro post Christian society
is God dead as Nietzsche once declared
or is there space for a renaissance of
religious belief in the modern world
John Lennox who is here on my left is
emeritus professor yeah give him a
runner
[Applause]
because to give a brief info John is
emeritus professor of mathematics and
the philosophy of science at Oxford
University he's a leading Christian
thinker and he's engaged many of the
world's leading atheist voices as well
his latest book is called can science
explain everything and it is available
as well after Dave Rubin is my other
guest let's have a round of
[Applause]
now Dave hosts the Reuben report it's an
online talk show that reaches millions
of people every week David's gonna be
telling us about his religious
background and where he's at now so I
won't sort of label him at this point
but he regularly hosts conversations
with leading cultural and religious
thinkers on his show so I'm really
looking forward to and he's going to be
bringing to this conversation today he
has a new book out it's available for
pre-order don't burn this book is the
title
thank you for yourself in an age of
unreason so I do recommend you go and
get that if you can on pre-order as well
so one more time just please give her a
warm round of applause - my guess
[Applause]
well welcome gentlemen base to tonight's
discussion I'm really looking forward to
what we're going to be covering tonight
because I've had you on the show before
John and very often I've put you in
conversation with maybe a quite firm
atheist someone like a Dawkins or a
napkins or a Michael ruse but I think
tonight's gonna be a little bit
different because I'm really looking
forward to hearing your story Dave we
haven't met before
battered tonight was the first time but
I've watched your stuff and I've seen
some of the people that you've
increasingly been talking to and being
influenced yourself and and it'll be
fascinating to hear where you're at now
in terms of both the cultural and
religious aspects of you well I've never
had anyone give me an intro and say
we'll label him later so I'm feeling
really undue pressure right now and I'm
the only one here from SoCal let's see
what happens well whatever those labels
may be I'm really looking forward to
what you're gonna bring to us tonight
perhaps we'll we'll start with you first
of all they tell us a little bit about
who you are growing up I know that you
came from a pretty religious family so
do you want to tell a little bit about
that and where you found yourself as you
grew up and as regards sort of faith and
so on sure first off I just want to say
what a pleasure it is to be here you
know I'm usually on the other side of
the interview and the reason I'm
particularly excited about tonight is
that I don't talk about this sort of
thing from a personal perspective that
often you know I've sat down with tons
of atheists you know Sam Harris and
Michael Shermer and Peter Bogosian and
that whole crew and I've talked to
plenty of people of faith like Bishop
Aaron and Rabbi Whoopi and plenty of
other people that come from from
different political perspectives and
personal perspectives and I always find
that I go into each interview with with
no agenda other than hearing their
thought
and seeing how that shakes out around my
worldview that being said I'm excited to
be here because I can sort of tell you a
little bit more about about where I come
from and sort of where I'm at so I grew
up in a conservative Jewish household in
New York we kept kosher we did Shabbat
on Friday nights while all the big
holidays but there was a strong secular
belief within that and as I was telling
you sort of backstage you know there's a
there's an interesting piece related to
Judaism that I think is a little
different than other religions in that
the ethnic tie to it at least in a
modern way is for most Jews more
important than the religious nature of
it specifically let's say beliefs
specifically because John is we were
talking about there are many many Jews
especially in Sciences and in
mathematics that aren't believers per se
but have a real cultural affinity and I
would say that that's sort of where I'm
at or at least where I've been over the
last couple years I actually am now in
the last few years and this has to do a
lot with being on tour with Jordan
Peterson for a year
Jordan and I did about a hundred and ten
stops in one calendar year in about 20
countries it was pretty amazing and when
you spend that kind of time listening to
a true innovative thinker I mean truly
the guy that I think is is the world's
most important public philosopher and
let's say you know talking about his
biblical lectures and talking about his
perspective on life and that there has
to be a bedrock of something that is
real and true outside of us and then how
he relates that through the biblical
stories it moved me it moved me over the
course of of the year that we did this
together
so I would say I'm secular basically in
my life but I definitely in the last
year have found that there has to be
something outside of
the rest of this makes no sense I mean
the part very briefly the part that you
know I'm really known for is the
political part that I was lefty and and
the difference between left on a
political conversion I had it right so
I'm usually much more comfortable
talking about my political conversion
than a religious one but but I would say
this that consistent with me talking
about sort of what's happened with the
postmodern left with the progressives
and we see this now where there's sort
of nothing that's empirically true and
any any given day you can feel anything
about any particular topic there's a
reason for that and the reason is
they've disconnected everything their
whole worldview is disconnected to
anything that came before them so that
that could be God or a religious set of
ideas or something like that so I'm
really really fascinated by that at the
moment and it's it's changing how I live
my life I just did it was Yom Kippur
which is the holiest day in Judaism I
was at a service that was actually at a
church in in Pasadena in Los Angeles
hosted by by Dennis Prager that I'm sure
many of you guys know about Dennis
Prager who many of you know so I'm sort
of I would say I'm in it the way you
guys are all in it well trying to find
some truth in the madness I'll be
interested to tease that out a little
more in Jude course I mean one one thing
I did notice is I I have seen just
watching some of your videos that there
definitely been a progression in your
thinking on this and and probably if you
go back a few years I think you had said
along the lines of you probably thought
of yourself as an atheist but evidently
that's not quite the case anymore well I
had a bunch of atheist high-profile
atheists on the show in a row yeah
starting with Sam Harris who I admire
and he's a good friend of mine and
Michael Shermer and Peter Bogosian and I
really love the intellectual side of
that I really really do love it and
that's not at the exclusion of anything
else actually but what I found was that
I had had a series of atheists on in a
row and then people online just can't
kept saying that I was an atheist right
and and then I sort of just said it one
day without did
it didn't mean anything to me sort of
one way or another it was almost it just
sort of came it just sort of came out of
my mouth one day and then two years ago
you know I do this off-the-grid August
thing where I literally locked my phone
in a safe and I don't look at any news
or television
I am completely offline and I really
disappear and I try to let my brain
reset and two years ago when I did it
one of the thoughts that I kept having
sort of in my in my piece was that I'm
not an atheist and I came back and I
said it in a very casual way and I just
did this live stream where I just sort
of said it very flippantly that I just
don't like the word atheist it doesn't
it doesn't fit what I believe I do
believe in something else even if I
can't completely articulate what it is I
think Jordan has gone a long way to
articulate the type of thing that I
believe in and I got a lot of a lot of
hate for that one because you know they
theists they don't like a converted
person either so you know you got to
watch out for that too so you know we
all have our own trappings but what I'm
most interested in is is talking to
people from all walks of life and
figuring out what the common stuff is
and what I like to frame that around is
a conversation about freedom and how do
we how do we limit government so we can
all believe what we want to believe and
think what we want to think and be part
of a society that's pluralistic and
decent for all of us John let's have a
bit of an introduction to you for those
who aren't familiar with you tell us
about your own faith journey up to this
point you now obviously speak to many
people all over the world about
Christianity but but where did it all
begin for you that began for me and let
me say as well how delighted I am to be
back in Costa Mesa and I've enjoyed in
the past some marvelous shows with
Justin and I'm just fascinated by what's
going to happen in the conversation
tonight but I grew up in Northern
Ireland which isn't always the best
start to discuss religion because it was
a divided community and there was a lot
of terrorism
was connected in a very complex way to
Christianity of both versions Protestant
and Catholic but the important thing was
that my parents were very unusual for
that kind of cultural context they were
Christian convinced Christians but they
weren't sectarian and that was very
unusual my father had a small business
we lived in a small town 15000 or so and
he tried to employ people from both
sides of the community no way did he do
that I once asked him I said dad it's so
risky and he was bombed for doing this
my brother nearly lost his life and he
said look he said I believe that every
person whatever they believe is of
infinite value because they're made in
the image of God going back to the
Hebrew Scriptures and therefore I will
employ across the community and that has
stuck with me and it's been very
important when you're discussing as I
often do with people that do not share
my worldview that always comes to my
mind here's a person in front of me and
it relates to what you were saying about
freedom I would connect with freedom
value that here's something outside of
my parents that gave every human being
dignity and finally that was point
number one the second thing was that
they allowed me to think now northern
ireland's often associative or religious
bigotry extreme fundamentalism all this
kind of thing and my parents were not
highly educated but they really gave me
space so my first encounter with
Christianity was not mind closing it was
mind expanding and I remember when I was
about 13 my father cable-only says
here's a book you need to read it was
Marx's Das Kapital I said dad have you
read it he said no
so why should I read it you need to know
what other people think I never forget
that it was sent a compass bearing the
third point is their Christianity was
credible morally credible they actually
lived what they believed so in that
sense I had a hugely privileged
background that didn't compress me into
a narrow-minded bigoted person and it
was noticeable when I went to Cambridge
in 1962 not 1862 I don't know anything
but when I went to Cambridge in 1962
many of my contemporaries from merit of
the moment they got out of the country
that was the end of any Christianity
because they'd never made it their own
they'd never thought about it but I'd
been encouraged to think about and that
sort of said the the compass bearings
there's one further point that really
shaped my life I was challenged in
Cambridge very early on by student at
table at night and he said asked do you
believe in God and then he said oh sorry
sorry sorry I shouldn't have asked you
that you're Irish
all you Irish believe in God and you
fight about it I'd heard that many times
but somehow it was different and I
thought gosh yes you know I've never
really met atheist you know in Ireland
people divided the Protestant atheist
and Catholic they're not really really
thin sighs so I thought what I'm going
to do is to start today and befriend
people to friend them that's important
that do not share my worldview and I'd
spent my whole life doing it so that's
that really sets the the scene I think
so
neech famously declared god is dead now
he may have been a bit premature in that
but maybe he's finally you know his
thoughts are coming true in 21st century
West because we are living in an
increasingly ocean
Christian age people say increasingly
the number of people who take the census
box that says none no religious
affiliation is going up and so on I mean
you're you're engaging with this kind of
demographic all the time on your show
Dave what's your feeling do you do feel
like people are genuinely less religious
now to what extent are the some of those
friends that you made early on in your
show people like Sam Harris and another
well-known atheist responsible for
people moving away from you know the
religious bearings that they once had so
obviously I don't want to speak for for
Sam or any of those guys what I have
found in the conversations that I've had
with non-believers and with believers is
that at a micro level you can be a
non-believer and be absolutely moral and
decent and well good and a productive
member of society and all of those
things as I believe those couple people
that I mentioned are what I think is
becoming the problem and I think this
was really where Jordan Peterson hit on
something is that societies can't
organize around that that it can sort of
work for a while and there's you know
most of the things that I believe in and
I you know I I talk about the individual
all the time and why I believe that
classical liberalism is the best sort of
framework for a political system that we
should have they almost can't exist
without that underlying bedrock and so
your question sort of gets to what I was
saying earlier which is that the reason
that the secular world feels so out of
control right now I mean just just
yesterday I'm sure some of you guys saw
the CNN did this quality Town Hall last
night and it was like you know everyone
has to mention their gender pronouns and
you have to admit that there are more
than two genders and all of these things
that you know these conversations are
not being had there are settled science
debates that went on for a long time
that we know we know what facts are and
yet we find because this has now become
untethered to anything other than how
you feel that now everything is up for
grabs and that's why it sort of feels
like that there's something sort of God
happening here or something like that
now trust me that is a that is a hard
thing for someone like me to say you
know as someone that really might my
beliefs really are rooted in the
Enlightenment and Enlightenment thinkers
and this is a real debate amongst people
who talk about the Enlightenment could
they have done it
could they have reformed religions and
first liberalism in a positive way
forward without some religious belief
behind it I don't know the answer to
that exactly I don't know that we'll
ever really know the answer to that but
I would say that the reason I first said
that I'm happy to be here with you guys
is that in the last year where now I've
virtually only get invited to events by
conservative groups or you know
libertarian groups for surebut groups on
the right let's say but I often get
invited to churches I often get invited
to places of faith now I know we can go
through a litany of political
disagreements that we may or may not
have and I absolutely know that everyone
in this room would be happy to do that
and there would be nobody fighting there
would be nobody screaming we could
explore those ideas as far as we can and
then we would put it down in front and
either agree to disagree or maybe maybe
we'd move each other one way or another
and that would be wonderful and I don't
think that's a coincidence I don't think
it's a coincidence that you guys here
and the generally believers right now
are more tolerant they are it's just the
reality the people yeah give yourselves
a round of applause
I mean that really is true who are the
most intolerant people in society right
now it's the people that are constantly
telling you how tolerant they are that's
the that's the irony it's the people
that tell you you're a bunch of racists
and bigots and homophobes in the rest of
it
and and that's the real bizarre flip
that we have happening in society and I
think that is linked to either however
you want to phrase it either a
post-christian world or a post
judeo-christian world or or a postmodern
world however you wanted to find that I
mean to what extent do you agree with
Dave's analysis there of what's going on
especially I suppose of that academic
level and in terms of the the kind of
conversations now that you are and
aren't allowed to have almost I think
it's a pretty accurate analysis and
that's what I experienced right there
I'm always interested in the phrase
God's dead because it seems to assume he
was alive once and of course I hear
Richard Dawkins kind of saying which God
and I think that's a question worth
addressing because the God that I
believe in that is the God of the Bible
is eternal and that raises problems for
the deadness doesn't it good but there's
a sense in which Nietzsche was a very
accurate prophet and what to my mind is
very important with him was that he
could see where many contemporary
atheists cannot see that if you abolish
God you wake the ground under any
solidity on which you can base on
morality human dignity freedom all those
values he saw that connection and he
says if you didn't bring God you've no
right in the end to value said you
notice where the values are realized in
our society they're mostly values that
go back to the judeo-christian tradition
and I think therefore to bring that back
into the discussion I like the idea and
I think it's very important start
where there's something more there's
something outside of us that's the start
it seems to me of coming back to
something around which society can be
organized because otherwise everything
is subjective and you mentioned
postmodern and it amuses me that so many
i but it's sad that so many of these
people will tell you as an absolute
truth that there is no truth urges sheer
nonsense yeah because it's a
contradiction in terms
yes I mean you you obviously spend quite
a lot of time speaking especially to
actually a lot of young people here so
know many of the events you do John do
you find that there's a kind of people
are looking again for a source of
meaning for something to hold onto
absolutely I think that well we it's
it's country-specific because there are
parts of the world of course and where
for example Christianity is growing like
wildfire but in the UK and in the u.s. I
find that young people find the world
that is presented to them by people like
the old New Atheists or the naturalistic
philosophy is too small to live it it
doesn't give them any kind of solid
foundation so they're looking again and
just what last week I spoke to several
whole West best or 1500 young people
starting at the age of 13 to 18
absolutely fascinated spending a whole
day thinking about these big ideas that
I find enormously encouraging when young
folks start asking these questions and I
find a huge response around the world
but it's self selecting you know it's
very difficult for me to give a global
and fair assessment I mean it strikes me
Dave that you did this hundred city tour
with Jordan Peterson and it strikes me
that the crowds that have flocked to
hear him talk about meaning in a
meaningful way I have been quite young
they're kind of proud that you kind of
might have expected more to be turning
out to hear their Sam Harris's and the
Christopher Hitchens and Richard Dawkins
and so on what what what's changed why
why in a sense is the conversation moved
on from well we all know God's dead -
well what's going to happen next I
suppose well it's really interesting
because if you were paying attention to
the the media around Jordan during the
year the implication somehow or the
condemnation I should say from the media
was that somehow this was for young
straight white men that he's only
talking to straight white men as if
inherently that's somehow an evil thing
right so that was the idea that he's
kids somehow he's really broken that
straight white men are showing up to his
events and that's somehow inherently
evil now of course that's absurd if it
let's say he was talking to all straight
young white men if he if he happened to
have been giving them something positive
that could put a little order in their
life away from the chaos as he would put
it that would actually be a wonderful
thing of course the irony is that that
actually wasn't even true at all because
the crowds were wonderfully diverse and
I usually thought they were about 60/40
male to female an age range all over the
place and all that but to answer your
question specifically I think that we
got as politics and the media and social
media and the fact that we're all
walking around with a phone in our
pocket that has the world's knowledge
and you can connect with somebody you
know literally across the world in a
split second I think we have no idea how
this information orgy basic yeah I think
we have no idea how it's affecting our
brains our ability to think clearly
about things it's doing wondrous things
right we're all here because of this
this is a podcast right we're
disseminating this through the digital
world this is incredible but it also has
destabilized sort of basic beliefs and I
think then Jordan stepped in and said we
have to be able to get some meaning out
of this so that's why he wrote twelve
rules he thought these are 12 rules in a
modern sense he wasn't handing down the
Ten Commandments again but he was saying
in a modern sense these are 12 things
you can do
stand up straight with your shoulder
back with your shoulders back
clean your room clean your room before
you clean the world these are basic
things where now we have people that
want to fix the world constantly that
can't fix themselves they're doing it
backwards but but just very briefly on
the the underpinning of some sort of
belief that can lead to freedom
and that's what sort of what I was
talking about about the Enlightenment
think about you know the the founding
documents of this country I think are
the greatest meant man written documents
let's say political documents at least
and what did the founders say they said
these are god-given rights they're
self-evident we did not give you these
rights the right of freedom own of free
speech all things we can protect these
things but we didn't give them to you
because they came from somewhere else
that is so deeply important and and in
many ways very unique to America and
that's why there's such a bizarre
assault on freedom of speech right now
and actually almost everything in the
Bill of Rights and it comes mostly from
the secular world that is a really sad
twist that truly I would not have
expected a couple years ago even as
someone that saw this coming I mean
right you know five years ago I was
waving me the flag going guys there's
something happening here on the Left
this progressive thing this is no good
but even it's gotten so crazy that I'm
still a little surprised myself to some
extent it's almost as though that the
meaning crisis has almost created this
vacuum and people are finding all kinds
of crazy things - oh yeah they're
looking anywhere you can look - you can
play video games all day you can you can
do whatever it is to fill up that hole
if it's an existencial hole or a hole in
belief or whatever it is but there's a
lot there's a lot of ways to fill that
hole I think Jordan Jordan in my opinion
has given the best set of beliefs that
take from a religious tradition and
blend what I would say our enlightenment
values are basically secular values
judeo-christian values and he's blended
them in the most effective way I mean as
we're on the subject talking about
Jordan Peterson I know that you're
somewhat familiar with some of what he's
been doing as well John what's your take
on what he's put his finger on the
obviously so many people are responding
to and and yeah well how does it relate
in your view to to the Christian paper
you home I think people are longing for
sense and you mentioned connectedness
that is almost replaced meaning but it's
not real connectedness and I was reading
a book on artificial intelligence just
recently and it was a warning that
people will die if they're not connected
to the Internet because all the meaning
is being placed there and they think
what Jordan Peterson is doing is putting
a nuclear bomb in the middle of that and
saying this is not good enough
you've got to get outside of that and
you're right it is rewiring brains the
the psychologists tell us it's messing
people's brains up especially if they
try and use two machines at once and
therefore I just think that there's an
underlying and from where I sit people
are looking for this because although
they often don't believe it or even I've
never heard of it they are made in the
image of God they're beings who've got
eternity in their hearts and a kind of
materialist universe without meaning
just won't satisfy them because they're
actually made for something bigger and
CS Lewis put it years ago if if you find
a lie in you that's not satisfied in
this world many there is another world
at which it could be satisfied and I'm
gonna play that to the world of ideas so
I really think he's hit a nerve and
interestingly if you read his book 12
rules for life and he's done yes I guys
mm-hmm there's he's drawing a great deal
on the Bible especially the Old
Testament sure yes especially the Old
Testament and it has intrigued me that
he has concentrated his lectures of the
Bible on the Old Testament that to me
resonates completely because I as a
Christian
have been for years trying to
communicate to people that they've got
to begin to take the Jewish Scriptures
seriously because there you've got the
foundation the foundation story and
people are looking for a story that's
big enough to fit their lives into and
there's the start of the big story
creation human beings made in the image
of God and what that means for their
dignity and their freedom and everything
else if we just get that one fact I
remember in Siberia where I used to go
quite a bit and I give the first lecture
in 75 years on these issues and the
University of no Xhosa beers and I made
the point I said just think of the one
statement human beings made in the image
of God and I said if I believed that
they wouldn't murder one of you let
alone 100 million was talented and it
absolutely erupted the place of course
they'd never heard it before it was
totally new to them and I think our
society needs to hear these truths in
Jordan Peterson is moving into that area
because he's actually going back to the
book and not being ashamed of it
I'm more power to them I say yeah and
just very briefly just from from being
on tour with Jordan I told you this
backstage but I never saw the guy break
one of the twelve rules I mean try to
imagine how chaotic his life was in the
course of this becoming a massive star
traveling all over the world the book
sales the celebrity the entire thing and
he never broke one one of those twelve
rules just twenty seconds we were at a
we were at a dinner party at Douglas
Murray's house with Majin woz and Jordan
you may know those guys and one of the
rules is that if you see a pet if you
see a cat in the street you should pet
it and Douglas had a cat
we're there for about three or four
hours we're having dinner we're having a
great time and I'm looking at the cat
the whole time and I'm looking at Jordan
I'm going the guy hasn't pet the cat
like you know what am I on tour with
this guy for the whole thing is it is he
a fraud you know what's going on here I
swear to God I was thinking at the
entire time and then as we were walking
out the door
Jordan literally and you can sort of
picture Jordi's he's very tall and he
has long limbs and he's slender and he
basically sat down in the cat's bed with
the cat and and Stroke the cat for a
good five minutes and I thought all
right he's the real deal
we should probably talk about someone
other than Jordan Peterson tonight yeah
the I mean I'd love to key in a little
bit more on your story because it sounds
like you have been on something of a a
journey of discovery over the last year
or two and obviously very much
influenced by the way Jordan was brought
alive in his lectures and so on so I
mean you obviously now are seeing more
and more the value of religion what what
does that caused you personally to do in
terms of maybe is it causing you to
rediscover your own Jewish roots a bit
more and the religious aspect of that
well I would say there's two things here
as I said at the beginning there's sort
of just the cultural affinity and the
understanding of the history of the
people that came before me which you
know unfortunately in the case of Jews
is a pretty brutal often almost
unimaginably horrific history and I you
know I grew up around Holocaust
survivors and and I know that that
though the pain of your ancestors or
whatever the the history of your people
is can't be the thing that defines you
going forward I would say as I've sat
down with believers and non-believers
alike I've genuinely found well I guess
sort of this would get to what you were
saying John I generally found the
believers not only more welcoming so
like in a situation like this but more
more open actually happier less less
dependent on
seems outside of themselves more
self-reliant let's say so I don't think
that means I'm going to be religious per
se tomorrow that being said as I said I
went to this Yom Kippur service that
Dennis Prager hosted and I found it
incredibly moving and you know Dennis
gave a sermon that you know he talked
all about judeo-christian values and
sort of what's happening in our country
right now and how it all seems to be
becoming untethered and he used some
religious backing to give some value
there and I thought well this is value
this is something a real world way that
I could come somewhere once a week or
build some community around or friends
that would have value so I can't say I'm
you know it's like if ultimately I can
see in your eye you want me to be like
yeah yeah Jesus let it go I can see if
there's a guy back there waving a Jesus
sign at me I see you well if you insist
yeah let's put it this way
I have no problem with Jesus I like the
guy you know I mean like the message of
Jesus that all of the things that we've
talked about here on stage and backstage
I love these ideas I think that if my
life becomes a continuing conversation
about these things and I can incorporate
the best parts of that to be a better
person
well I'll tell you this I I know for a
fact I am a better person today than I
was before I started this journey with
Jordan but those things and that doesn't
mean I prescribe to the Church of Jordan
Peterson but that is just that this guy
who is communicated the bedrock ideas
that we're talking about here by me
listening to that and hearing that and
incorporating some of that in my life
I'm a better person so that that means
something you know even any comments on
on Dave's journey so far feel like this
is my life haha do it you're on there
right so I kind I well I think what
struck me just listening was you're
being moved by young people
I'm not Jewish by background but I owe
everything to Jews and the history of
the Jews has been enormous ly important
to me and when you mention the Holocaust
as you do and I've been in Auschwitz
many times I've wept every time and I
have many Jewish friends who lost
everybody and that raises huge deep
existential questions and therefore just
thinking of the big picture the big
biblical story and I love it because
although there are all sorts of twists
and turns and difficulties I see the
Jewish history the history of Israel the
law the prophets as pointing toward
something big because at the heart of
Judaism many Orthodox friends who still
expect tamashii arcs and Messiah to come
there is the difference is that I
believe he has come and Yom Kippur means
a huge amount to me because in those
Jewish festivals and I've been at many
of them I see I know what to put a
crudely but a thought model that has
been fulfilled in what Jesus did and I
find Yom Kippur moving because I see in
him the fulfillment of it and here is a
person who actually died the day of
atonement
it's an atonement to deal with now here
comes the point that what happens when
you start with a creation story of
people made in the image of God that's
wonderful but we know that something has
happened a bomber said the human race
huge problems and we long for a solution
we long for justice we long for to
freedom we long for truth
News and we've got to therefore face the
problem of human rebellion against God
know the sin word is not popular these
days but it seems to me that there's a
fulfillment within what Jesus did and
taught a fulfillment that everything
that Judaism stood for and stands for
powerfully and therefore I I feel a
close affinity here the whole Judeo
tradition is immensely important to me
because there I find these fundamental
values but they raise a big question and
it's the fulfillment of that the whole
history of Israel its sacrifices the
institution's the prophets looking
forward to Messiah who will deal with
the basic problem of human rebellion and
so that's clearly a difference between
me and Judaism but I wouldn't under
emphasize the huge contribution that it
has made to the rock on which I believe
I stand today if that makes sense
well it does make sense and if I could
quickly I actually do want to answer
your question a little more specifically
now that I had a moment to think it
through
so this year I went my parents live in
New York still in the same family home
that I grew up in and I went to a temple
on Rosh Hashanah and Rosh Hashanah is
the beginning of the new year and it's
it's about creation and then basically
you have the week or so between Rosh
Hashanah and Yom Kippur where you're
supposed to think about your life the
things that you've done the good things
that you've done the bad things don't
apologize to people if you've done you
know whoever you may have done harm and
I really did so this is this is the real
answer your question I really did that
this year I really did think about it
probably didn't fully get there on
Twitter throughout the week I probably
did drop the ball a couple times on
Twitter but I but I really was very
aware of that and and I tried you know
just a few days ago at services I really
was trying to be cognizant of it doesn't
thoroughly matter if I believe in all of
this all of it fully but there is value
in this this story that has been told by
my parents and my grandparents and my
great-grandparents going way back when
there must have been something that kept
this thing alive and there must have
been some reason behind it and for me to
pretend that I'm so enlightened that I
have figured out something that is so
brilliant that I could that I could just
set all that aside that it to me that
strikes me is the worst sort of like
egomaniacal hubris that you could have
so I would be happy to do this again
next year and we can continue the
conversation of the Jesus guys still
waving III I'm finding this fascinating
because obviously there has been
something of a spiritual awakening and
and I think yeah it sounds like you're
saying I'm not quite sure what that
looks like exactly but I want to start
to investigate and live into this kind
of tradition more that obviously your
forebears have done so I mean there's
there's a lot of people out there you
know he would say come on wake up it's
the 21st century
we all know that these are just
superstitions and everything else and
you need to get on the bandwagon of
reason you're about reason Dave and and
if we just think straight
work things out with science and logic
then then that's the way forward that's
the way you religion is kind of the way
we used to do things not anymore yeah
well I think the counter to that would
be that everything that Jordan has
talked about not not to bring this back
to Jordan but the counter of that is
that we'll look sort of where the
secular world is that where we can't
figure out whether you're male or female
anymore we have to now debate that I you
know I don't it's sort of like I don't
like using that one because it's so easy
and it sounds sort of sort of glib and I
don't mean it to be that way but that is
where this is all leading if there is
nothing outside of ourselves then John
as you said everything else is
subjective and we will debate every
little thing to be
dude depending on how we feel about it
on any given day and that that will lead
there is there's a reason why right now
the idea of socialism is suddenly
popping up in America which is the
genuinely the worst set of collectivist
ideas that you could possibly ever have
that hundreds of millions of people have
died in history under and it's popping
up because if you listen to what's
happening on the Left right now
politically because they've outsourced
god imagine if one of those people on
stage said that they were a real
believer imagine if any of them maybe
Biden could do it but but but really the
rest of them can they would never really
say that they're a believer now I don't
know what they are and I wouldn't want
them to say anything that's not true to
themselves but they will be mocked by by
everything mainstream everything
mainstream would mock them the way that
everything mainstream mocks any
Christian that happens to be could
they're usually on the right they happen
to be conservatives but look what
they're offering us now their answer is
oK we've removed God from the equation
and what do we get we get government and
they they now pray basically the
government they think that they can
figure out somehow by sitting in a room
with a bunch of other politicians and
bureaucrats the worst sort of people
that exist they I didn't even need that
to be funny
I mean but that's what they think they
think that they can rejigger all of
humanity in a way that will be so much
better than everything that came before
them and not only can't they they are
going to do the complete reverse so that
if for no other reason if for no grand
revelation or something like that that
would be a reason to be respectful of
people that are believers because they
can fight that in a way that secularists
can't the good liberals don't have
enough juice in and of them in and of
themselves they don't have enough juice
to fight that that's why liberalism has
collapsed in the name of progressivism
yeah I approach this in two ways the
first one is your comment that
secularism is collapsing and one can
analyze the defects of atheism or leads
to in the millions of people that died
in the last century but coming over to
the other side what you're saying Justin
you see I am a scientist and one of the
fascinating things is that science is a
direct legacy of the judeo-christian
tradition
you were saying we're all scientists now
and all this is no it is not and let's
start absolutely basic in the beginning
God created the heavens and the earth
Hebrew Bible written millennia ago knew
there was a beginning it was in the
early 60s before scientists caught off
of that and the Bible was right and
Dawkins said well there was a 50/50
chance when I debated him and I said at
least the Bible got it right but more
seriously than that you see the fact
that I'm a mathematician and interested
in science I just think about that the
fact that mathematics can describe what
goes on in the universe is a matter of
huge wonder Einstein once said the only
incomprehensible thing about the
universe is
principal and he saw the problem why
does it work well it's not an
incomprehensible thing if you start from
the idea that there's an intelligent god
who made us in His image and therefore
we can do science and that's exactly
what the early pioneers of modern
science starting with Galileo and Kepler
and Newton and so on and so forth they
were all believers in God and therefore
when I hear that kind of question I'm
not remotely ashamed of being a
scientist or a Christian because I want
to argue that it was Christianity gave
me my subject and see us knows put it
brilliantly
[Laughter]
I'm glad you understood at them CS Lewis
said men became scientific because they
expected law in nature and they expected
law nature because they believed a
little lawgiver and I think we're
getting to the stage now we're serious
atheist thinkers are beginning to
reexamine the kind of naturalism that
produces everything to physics and
chemistry and one of them lives in New
York his name is Thomas Nagel and he's a
brilliant philosopher and he says
something's going wrong because of
everything is reducible to physics and
chemistry then so is your mind but then
why would you trust your mind
in other words atheism taken to its
logical conclusion undermines the very
rationality you need to trust to do
science and I'm not in for accepting a
worldview that undermines the
foundations of any kind of argument or
discussion whatsoever so I think that in
the 21st century we can push back on
that very naive notion that God's art we
do science now no science actually
brings God back in it's very interesting
I mean all of this leads me to want to
ask you at this point you sitting down
with John here tonight obviously a
Christian believer someone who gives
evidences for God and I know that on
your show you've you've had people like
we should pairen and I think Ravi
Zacharias is gonna be featured shortly
and where does this leave you on if you
like that God question because one level
I can absolutely see the way in which
there's a kind of utility and a kind of
sense in which meaning Mithen meaning
from doing the religious things the
rituals and so on but at the end of the
day and I asked mr. Jordan Peterson once
it was an interesting answer do you
believe in God do you feel like that's
where you've got to at this point in
your life you know it's funny when we
would do the Q&A at the shows with
Jordan for the first few we would let
people come up to the microphone and
what usually happens is that people
start telling their life story and they
they would want to get that therapy
session in front of strangers and it
started getting very weird so we decided
we decided to better rate it we used an
app to do it and when Jordan was on
stage basically I would go through the
best ones and I'd find some funny ones
and some serious ones and everything
else but what always came up no matter
how many times
Jordan answered it was do you believe in
God and he and as I'm sure he said to
you he finds it to be sort of the most
annoying question so I think I would
answer it I mean I would answer it in a
similar way that Jordan would that look
I think I've I've sort of laid out a set
of beliefs here that show the utility of
believing in something outside of myself
and I do I do believe in that so if you
want to call that God that there is
something outside of me there is
something that is connecting all of us
that has nothing to do with the material
world there is something that drives us
that that is the driver of humanity that
is something good I believe that I don't
yeah I believe that but could you put a
name on that something at this bed
I told you I wanted to label you Jesus I
I guess I I mean in a sense I I hear
what you're saying do I get a cookie at
least I didn't come on people what are
you doing here
I I guess I guess it's kind of like what
are the particulars of what would that
look how is that gonna make a difference
I suppose in your life is is there a
sort of sense in which you feel now any
new obligations given this kind of new
sense that there's there is something
beyond you know I think we're all sort
of wired differently right I think some
people can really really flourish just
sort of on on their own set of ideas
that they create in the world and I
think that can really work for some
people I think some people need some
order outside of that some people need
more of a community some people are real
loners all of those things I think
perhaps but I but I truly mean what I
said before I'd be happy to do this
every year with you and continue
continue these conversations and I'll
continue them on my show obviously I
think for me the adventure of discussing
this and seeing what kind of people that
I bring into my studio that I interact
with that events like this what type of
people I want to be around that really
is the proof that that is what well
that's what makes this right that's what
makes this so I don't know so again I
can't what you're I get the question I
respect the question truly and it's and
it's a it's the question right I mean
it's like saying what's the meaning of
life that's the big one I would say I'm
on the adventure to finding that out and
and I'm really okay with that you know I
hope that doesn't sound dismissive of
the question or or like I'm trying to
evade it I'm really not I like B and
maybe this is just a function also of
what I do for a living I mean I get to
sit every week with people that in most
cases are smarter than me who
spent years working through all of these
issues as you have John and that is an
incredible privilege that I have so I
would like to see how far I can take
this it sounds like we're not gonna
convey him tonight you're doing your
best working overtime over there I'll
say that much but it's wonderful to hear
an open description of a journey and I
try to think my way into this that
getting around these ideas is really big
stuff I mean coming the way you've moved
from the little I've understood of it
just meeting you for the first time it's
most interesting to me the way that the
movement isn't going now from where I
sit there's another element comes into
it what I mean by that is this there's
the things that we can think about
existentially as you're doing and that's
vastly important to me as well the kind
of people you like to be with thee
evidence of that you like this if you
feel there's something I'd side yourself
and so on and so forth but then it comes
to a couple of questions one is could it
be that something is actually personal
you're Jewish Hebrew Scriptures would
say exactly so because that's how better
Sheikh Genesis starts with a God who
sees you blesses who speaks and one of
the most interesting things to me both
as a scientist and a believer in God is
the simple description of creation and
God said let there be light
and God said and God said there's a
sequence as you know but the most
exciting one is the one you never hear
it's the final one and God said to them
and that opens up a whole world
ability that what is being claimed at
least is that there's a God that speaks
to me and that means that opens up the
possibility of Revelation where it's not
simply me investigating the people I
know the things I hear the arguments
philosophically and so on but there's
another side to it but if this is true
then God is interested in me and he's
wanting me as a discussion partner he's
wanting to talk to me and if what is
open to that possibility it seems to me
to open a huge new dimension to this and
the more I think about that this is a
word based universe scientifically and
religiously in that sense and and
therefore the idea that there's
something there that's fantastic there's
more than the material world but if not
more is personal and can speak to us
it's worth testing the claim at least
because it runs right through the whole
of the Hebrew Scriptures the New
Testament that's the fundamental thing
is a speaking God not dead
we I should say I mean we normally never
on on my show get to this point because
most of the time the person sitting
opposite someone like John is a
confirmed atheist and and it's really
God is always going to be debated in the
abstract John John you kind of come to
the point we're saying well let's look
at where the God could be personal here
that whether God could speak to us again
I feel like we're grilling you tonight
but I guess no it's fine nice thing I
did I I genuinely I love this there's
nothing you could ask me I don't think
that would that would offend my you I
really I'm grateful you being an open
book tonight because I suppose my next
question simply could could it be do you
think that it's possible that there
could be a God who is personally
interested in you who listens to your
prayers who is interested in the way you
live your life who wants the best of you
you know is that something that's on the
table as a possibility for where your
journey might take us but if he walks
out on food right now I would get
baptized okay like if that's like like a
you know Maury Povich and yes well my
basic answer would be yes why would I
why would I rule that out what why would
I rule that out well I as you said that
so eloquently would I be like no
you know it just that just doesn't stand
to reason and that again goes back to
why I said I love having these
conversations and I don't I don't even
though this is a little different for
what you do usually I don't take offense
by it or anything like that like that
that's interesting to me but and by the
way I think that this is sort of where
we're Jews maybe have done something a
little bit differently where it always
has been about this sort of battle about
what God is there you know you talk
about science and mathematics you can go
to most of the like the Jewish hospitals
in New York City where they have you
know the best doctors in the entire
world many of them are Orthodox Jews who
actually won't press the elevator on
Shabbat because they don't want to use
electricity don't rabat so they have the
baby elevators that go to every floor on
saturdays now from an outsider
perspective you weren't really thinking
about it that way you'd go well that's
completely crazy how are these people of
science and math doctors how would they
possibly care in this in this crazy
superstition if if you come from that
discipline of science and math and yet
they those people don't find it to be in
conflict so I don't see any of this in
conflict actually if anything I feel
like this is really what it's about
this this ability to to play because I
know that there are plenty of you guys
out there that are at some level of
where I'm at with some of this stuff
it's not like everyone that walks in
these doors is going this is absolutely
what I believe and we believe the same
thing and I want to convert everybody to
believe in the same thing I do I just I
don't believe that I'm not gonna poll
you don't worry but but I know that's
true and and we're all on those journeys
to the others so I so of course I don't
dismiss could God be a personal you know
do we all have do we all have that piece
of us behind us that that knows what's
right when when you when you make a bad
choice in life yeah up those my I
shouldn't have that drink or shouldn't
do this or whatever it is I don't know
is that a personal relationship with God
when you have that other thing or some
would say is that just the voice in your
head what is that what is
that thing I mean philosophers have been
debating this forever I think that's a
really great place just to draw this
part of the conversation to a close so
fake oh there's a lot for you I'm afraid
I I mean there is one very obvious one
which someone wants to ask and if you
could this could be a whole evening for
you John but someone simply asks what
for you would be the key evidences for
God if you were in a conversation with
someone about that it depends entirely
whom I'm talking to because it seems to
me there are two kinds of evidence
there's the object of kind of evidence
that is from the scientific point of
view looking at the universe the
beginning the fine-tuning of the
universe and all those pointers the very
doing of science that point to an
intelligence behind the universe that
would be one set the second set would be
the whole revelation through Christ and
who he is and what he did and all that
kind of thing and central to it of
course would be the fact that I believe
the death problem has been solved in the
sense that at the heart of Christianity
there's not only a death but a
resurrection which validates the
significance of the death so I want to
go into the what I believe of the
evidences for the resurrection
historically and so on and then finally
there's the existential sight many
people say to be you can't be a
Christian and a scientist because
Christianity is not testable and I say
of course it's testable and to be blunt
about that very briefly Christ makes
certain claims that if we trust him
he'll give us peace with God
forgiveness new life a new par you can
test that and you know in my life which
has been quite long I've met many people
and you make them and there maybe in the
midst of a broken relationship narcotic
dependence all kinds of stuff and you
meet them six months later and they're
completely different and you say what's
happened to you now they may express it
in different terms they may say well I
became a Christian or I was born again
or I was converted but when you see that
as I have done again and again not only
in my own life and those around me but
in people around you add thun thun he
get four and I wouldn't sit here from
now no second as a Christian if I didn't
believe it can be tested in real
experience if it doesn't work then it's
very suspect so that is the fastest
answer I can give to that thank you very
much ready for the answers that that's a
lot of thinking boiled down into a very
brief answer question for you Dave is
come in and it's what do you find
unbelievable
about Christianity so I guess the
question is okay you're on a journey or
you're willing to be open to that
potential answer what are the main
objections at this point that you would
have to to kind of embracing that kind
of well I suppose it's a good question
because I don't have a particularly good
answer for it so I think we could
probably do this one pretty quickly I
mean I I don't there's no well other
other than what would be a generic
answer about any religion let's say some
sort of like true leap of faith to
ultimately say this whether it's
Christianity or Judaism or whatever you
want to say whatever religion the reset
of ideas were done that beyond that full
jump I don't have any there's there's
nothing there's nothing that's been set
up here that's not there's nothing that
John has talked about or than any of the
religious thinkers that I've had on
recently the conversation that I had
with Ravi Zacharias the torn-up next
week I think is one of the best
interviews that I've ever been part of
there was nothing that he said there in
the course of that hour and
that I found objectionable or I found
completely incongruent with my set of
beliefs let's say so I don't know that I
have there's no answer for that in that
I'm willing to keep continue that
conversation I'm a few people have asked
a follow-up question effectively which
is I mean dude deep it's phrased in a
few different ways so I'll try and is it
hot here it's it's kind of goes to the
heart of Christianity though which is
what do you think about the central
claim that Jesus rose from the dead
because that at the end of the day is at
the heart of the faith John holes is
that something you would be open to
investigating to kind of you know seeing
whether there's anything in that that
claim yeah I look I think I don't know
how many of these types of questions
there's going to be too many books but
yes I can't I wish I could think of a
better way to say it but I am completely
open to these discussions as they have
your answer actually John was perfect
that if these things weren't testable in
that you you did not see the evidence
that people were living better lives
more fulfilled lives happier lives all
those things that you wouldn't as a man
of science you could not sit up here
that's a really beautiful answer that
that feels to me to be complete as a
person of faith in a person of science
right and and I think that would be a
worldview that I could prescribe to and
that is that actually is a worldview
that I prescribe to and that doesn't
exclude the fact that very early on I
said that at the micro level some of my
best friends are atheists and they are
and they are deeply moral good decent
people and you've debated many of them
so there's no there's no there's no
there's nothing that is so separate
thanks say I mean IIIi I promise no more
I don't know more grilling you on on
faith questions but the for John a kind
of the opposite question coming in is um
is there have you ever questioned if
there is a God and another person asks
well whether you've ever been presented
with an objection that you found if
oh can I do that one of course I have
you see this interest be because I spent
my whole life not only questioning
myself but exposing myself to some of
the most powerful questioners in the
world who are against my viewpoint and
the reason for doing that is partially
the Freudian one the accusation that was
made against me I came with you believe
because your parents really evenly
around parents believe in an Irish
genetics and the story so I have
questioned everything in that sense and
it's through that my certainty comes you
see the word faith has flicked in murder
this conversation and we need to be
careful what we mean by that by faith I
don't mean a leap into the dark I mean a
step into the light that's
evidence-based and it's exactly the same
kind of commitment in science we believe
certain things about the universe
because we've evidence now in
Christianity it is exactly parallel real
faith is a commitment a step based on
evidence and of course there's a
personal dimension to Christianity that
doesn't occur when you're believing
Einstein's equations for example it's
not quite the same as trusting a person
but still it's got to be evidence-based
or else is blind and blind faith is
extremely dangerous particularly in the
sphere of religion so asking questions
all the time is a process that I
discover in the Bible itself which is
one of the things that makes it credible
Jesus was always asking questions and he
didn't always answer them and his
disciples were asking questions my great
intellectual hero was Socrates who was
forced to commit suicide because he
corrupted the youth of Athens which
meant that he taught kids to ask
questions there
couldn't answer which is usually what
kids do but it seems to me that it's
very important
my whole process of relating to people
as Dave's this is asking them questions
and getting them to open themselves so
yes absolutely this this is the way the
thing works and that is where insurance
comes it's fear that stops us
questioning the propositions or the
commitments or off or what we believe
and I want to break through that fear
barrier and get into a proper public
discourse there's a question here which
relates to a story you told on your
podcast as of being I think a John
Peterson lecture night and you met a
couple who had both been through a
difficult time perhaps you can tell the
story I think a miscarriage is involved
and there were difficulties in the
family and the way you responded was was
the interesting house part of that story
as well you want to tell the story and
and just maybe dig into that of it
because the person asks that they just
like to hear a little bit more about
yeah I you know it's so interesting that
someone's asking this because I actually
don't remember telling this story
publicly but I must have said it
publicly at some point I don't remember
we were in the UK I don't remember what
what city we were in but a couple came
up to me before the show and they both
they both look very they were just sort
of destroyed you know sometimes you
people come up to you and you could just
see it in their face you could feel in
their body language and they started
talking to me and
basically it turned out that he was
young couple I mean they were in there
maybe late 20s early 30s and the guy had
just found out that he had like stage
four cancer and didn't have much time to
live and then yeah I mean that you can't
believe it is actually real the the
woman found out that she was pregnant
she was a few months pregnant and the
fetus had died and she was gonna have to
have it removed like the next day or
something like that I mean like
unimaginably horrific circumstances and
they said this to me and then said that
you know Jordans helped them get a
little meaning over the last few weeks
as they've been going to doctors and all
of these things and I think the reason
that the the persons mentioning that I
bring it up is the only thing that I
could say was god bless you god bless
you guys that's what I said I had there
was nothing else there was just nothing
else I could say what I possibly say I'm
sorry to hear about what you're going
through you know I hugged them my ID to
just kind of stand there and be with
them but that happened to be what popped
up in my brain so if that in a weird way
if that is evidence of something if that
is that when faced with unimaginable I
mean no one can possibly imagine the
level of horror of that situation
I hope I'm getting it fully technically
right that that's what that's what I had
left I would say it was the only words
that about kept mine they said yeah
because they didn't answer your question
and one of your questions to me was do
you make objections that you find
difficult to answer and I do and that's
one the problem of moral evil and pain
which is what you talked about is the
hardest question that any of his face
and it has been a very important part of
my life to try and think that through I
arrived in Christchurch New Zealand two
days after the earthquake and I had to
cancel all my talks and replace them
with earthquake
now that's not easy to deal with the
atheists say well it's just the way the
world is there is no God that's just
what you'd expect but you see if you
abolish God and I'm not gonna go into
details in this but it's hugely
important if you're Bali's God actually
you can make the problem worse because
there's no no hope if you bring God into
the equation from the Christian
perspective there is the hope of the
Resurrection and not going into it in
detail I want to say two big things to
this problem they're not answers that
would be simplistic and trivial but
there are a window into a possibility
and the window into the possibility is
this if it really is true that that's
God incarnate on the cross what does it
mean well at the very least it means
that God has not remained distant from
human suffering he has become part of it
and so your God bless you I think it's a
huge layers of meaning underlying it
that's the first thing and the fact that
Jesus rose from the dead means that
ultimately there is real hope why
because one of the things the early
Christians preached was that the
resurrection guaranteed a final judgment
and we don't like that idea but think
about it if there's going to be an
utterly fair assessment although they
said I've been to Auschwitz many times
if there's going to be a judgement the
deals were these things that gives me a
window of hope and so therefore I think
this is the hardest problem for anybody
and any philosophy in any world for you
nobody escapes it a question fit for you
this time John and maybe you might want
comment on it as well Dave but someone
asked what does it take for a person to
move from an abstract intellectual
belief
to add this personal experiential faith
wish well that's assuming that they
start with an abstract faith now people
come different ways our journeys and
that's why it's so interesting talking
about journey and I haven't finished my
journey yet there are lots of questions
I've got the things unresolved I started
by the existential side the personal
side I saw it was real but then as a
child I was taught to ask the question
so the intellectual side and the
practical side walked handed hand
throughout my life and some people come
to faith in Christ because they've been
befriended by somebody that shows a real
friendship and it's existential others
come because they've been challenged
intellectually I was speaking in Germany
a week ago and speaking with a very
intellectual person and what started him
off in his journey was at school he was
grown up and grew up in a home where all
his father said about everything was
everything's lies that was his
everything's lies total skepticism and
he had a school friend they sat together
and the school friend said then one day
he said Jesus Christ rose from the dead
and this chap thought what and he
started to investigate it and that led
him to become an ancient historian and
now in Germany he filled a hall with
5,000 people talking about how he became
a Christian from scepticism so the
intellectual side got him first
so you can't generalize at all but I I
think in that sense if a person is just
cerebral about a devil understood it
because Christ does make demands there's
a relational thing there are moral
dimensions to it and so it needs to move
how shall I put it
I'm worried about the distinction
because even when we're emotional about
something the emotions are precipitated
by our thoughts you can't separate
thought and emotion but I think the
important thing is that since let me put
it this way
God is not simply a philosophical theory
he's a person and therefore our response
to persons is different from a response
to say a mathematical equation and we
need to take the various dimensions and
aspects into account so I'd simply want
to encourage a person like that to think
about well what does Christy
Christianity mean that you should be
doing but since it's an abstract
question I don't know the person
everybody's different I'm tossing over
to you Dave there's a sense in which you
know we've talked a lot about all the
beats from this evening but when I see
him on stage he's not afraid of getting
emotional
in fact he quite frequently is posted
tears very often when it's talking about
search for the search for meaning when
he's engaging with where people are at
in their struggles and so on and in that
sense he's quite the antidote to the
kind of very coldly rational kind of
approach that many sort of big thinkers
often take to these issues is that
something that's attracted you Ida noted
to the way in which he engages with that
kind of aspect of reality and a very
personal way in a sense in which which
he approaches these kinds of issues yeah
well I can answer that two ways first
not specifically with Jordan but I think
one of the reasons that the YouTube game
and the podcast game and all of the
digital stuff and all of this this new
set of personalities that you guys all
watch and consume and listen to the
reason it's working is because these
people are being people these are actual
people I mean the person that you see
when I'm doing something on YouTube
that's this guy that's right in front of
you right now I happen to be on stage or
the mic but I'm the same person when I
step down there and talk
you guys Jordan is the same person as I
said he lived those 12 rules he's the
same exact guy right there's a little
something when there's a camera there I
forget what the the sight there's a
theory you know that you all you went at
Amazon you turn it on like five percent
or something but I think what's happened
over the last 20 or so years with cable
news is that everyone on television
became so incredibly fake and over
prepared and and really ridiculously
robotic that there is a breath of fresh
air when people just actually are decent
when people just actually can look each
other in the eye and not pretend that
they have every answer to every question
I think that's a deeply powerful thing
so when Jordan would go onstage and he I
kid you not I I it's almost unimaginable
but the guy 110 some nachos that we did
together he never gave the same lecture
twice he would give a difference um
nights he would talk about all 12 rules
some nights he would talk about one rule
some nights four rules some nights he
would just talk about the media some
nights he we talked about YouTube I mean
it was just whatever was in his mind and
and you know the book he was on a book
tour they wanted him to sell a book
sometimes the book never came up I mean
he he just didn't he but but to answer
your question specifically he was being
present as much as possible
that is something that I really try to
do in my life and when you're doing it
right you don't really have to try
because it just starts happening and you
just start being real and that's why
actually I've thoroughly as I just said
to you guys at halftime or whatever
we're calling it the Dave Rubin grilling
[Music]
I've really enjoyed this because this is
real this is real and the more that we
can do that the better the better we can
understand each other so there would be
nights where he would be on stage you
know telling the story that I'm sure
many of you have heard where he talks
about Pinocchio and the reason that you
have to wish upon a star and what that
means and then he would link it to the
to a biblical story and and he would
tear up and he would cry and you could
cure the crack in his voice and it was
real that we would be backstage right
after the show just sitting in the
greenroom and I'm just kind of sit there
and give him his moment to collect
himself so it was real and I think all
that really is
is being vulnerable being open being he
was the best way I could describe it was
what I saw the guy do was that every
night that he went onstage he tried to
take as much of his intellect and his
set of beliefs he would take them as far
as he could on any given night and there
were nights where I could see him
stretch that a little bit further that's
a pretty incredible thing to be around
on a slide he lied today someone else
Jordan Peterson vs. Ben Shapiro
wrestling match
[Laughter]
well Jordans tall and lanky Ben is quick
and short so I feel like he'd take out
the legs you know Ben battle site you
know Ben's without you know 20 years
younger so so so many of these questions
actually you could use the yarmulke it
some kind of boomerang or something you
know there's things the guy can do
here's a serious question what am I
doing here
really this is a tough one I mean I know
I've heard this you put this position
but as much as you obviously have a
great deal of respect for people like
Ben Shapiro and other religious figures
they you disagree with them on some
pretty fundamental things symmetrical
issues for instance so for instance ben
shapiro is very strongly opposed to
abortion and someone asks you on text
here what what about you what would it
take to change your position on that
particular ethical issue knowing that
you are pro-choice so I describe myself
as burger but grudgingly pro-choice
which I take no pleasure in even
discussing abortion I find this to be
the issue beyond any other political
issue I find this to be the most
polarizing and almost impossible to talk
about because you're talking about
you're talking about the most
existential questions there is which is
the beginning of life right and the way
that it gets framed unfortunately
through the media is that if you're on
the right you somehow hate women and if
you're on the left you somehow hey
babies and that that sort of ridiculous
false choice that we're constantly
basically playing ping-pong
between is insane my position basically
is that look I believe in the individual
now I get why that could be messy in a
conversation about abortion because I do
believe that a fetus is life I do and we
can edit up to ethicists and
philosophers and all sorts of scientific
minded people and and theologians
actually as well to decide is that the
moment the sperm meets the egg or is
that two weeks later and there's
different religious traditions that can
teach you all sorts of different things
by my belief is that the individual we
we as a society cannot have a perfect
system that is perfect for everyone all
the time
what we can try to do is have some set
of rules that can maximize human
flourishing the most it can what what I
believe is basically that you have a
couple week window I you know a few
years ago and the first time I debated
this with ben shapiro who's obviously
completely pro-life so he's completely
anti-abortion
I used to say twenty weeks because there
was scientific evidence that at twenty
weeks the fetus can actually feel pain
and what Ben said to me which i think is
a completely legitimate argument well so
you're saying you're admitting it's a
life and you're acknowledging well if
you're saying twenty weeks well then
eighteen weeks is obviously still alive
why not eighteen weeks and I granted him
that inconsistency in this in this view
because I'm not trying to come up with a
perfect system I'm trying to come up
with some system that would allow the
350 million people without live in this
country to have some some guideline that
we could most somewhat agree on
something like that the problem right
now is that the twelve Democratic
candidates have gone so off the deep end
with this that they're talking about I
mean they're literally talking about
post birth abortions like we have heard
some beyond hysterical crazy stuff tulsi
gabbard we had on my show she said that
she would not want third term abortions
which by any measure even if it's not
for you guys let's say here because I'm
assuming you're mostly pro-life that was
a that would have been considered a
pretty moderate position for a Democrat
ten years ago but for her now in that
field that is a wildly out their
position because they all believe
basically you can have an abortion
I mean this is even where Biden was
supposed to be the adult in the group is
now kind of right he's supposed I mean
that's why they dragged him back into
this he didn't want to do it there you
know but he was supposed to be the the
adult and go guys know you're all
bananas and you know settle down but
it's it's not working so what's your
question what would get me to change
well I suppose that that would be a
really interesting thing that to ask
would would would this journey that
you're going on as being open to to
potentially God into religious answers
to things cause you to to reconsider you
I would say these things don't have
nothing to do with each other right so
if we find you know if we find a speck
of something on the moon that some has
some resemblance of life or a cell or
something we say it's life so I'm not
denying that that from conception I'm
actually not denying that's like what
I'm trying to do just as someone that
talks about things in a public way is to
you're not gonna satisfy everybody all
the time
and by the way the the most
uncomfortable truth about this is that
humans get left with all sorts of
horrific choices that they don't want to
have to deal with and if abortion was
completely illegal that actually would
not stop abortion it would also make it
much more dangerous there would be
access for people that had certain
resources financially that other people
wouldn't have it is very complex there's
just a series of uncomfortable truths
that we would have to deal with to do
that but I would say I would say I'm
grudgingly pro-choice and and trust me
this is this one more than a than a god
question because this is a sort of
policy issue I mean up here and now I
find it to be the most difficult one to
answer
I mean Jonah I just finished in your
reflection on this not necessarily
getting to the bottom of this issue
which which could take us all evening
but but to what extent for you does
being a believer in God and specifically
Christianity mean that your views on
that kind of thing have to take a
certain direction in terms of the views
of abortion and the sanctity of life in
that case I think the important thing to
realize and we don't focus it sharply
enough is that in part ethics our
worldview dependent what I mean by that
is this if you think
that a fetus is just simply at the early
stage of undifferentiated block of cells
it's only matter why not deal with it as
has been put to me to a walk by a
world-class gynecologist and I pointed
out to her I said but you come to that
because of your atheism now I said to
her what would you do
that's not only life after conception
it's human life from where I said it
bears the image of God what right have I
to stop it so that the ethics are
worldview dependent and this is one of
the huge problems way beyond that
question you know if we teach kids in
school that they are purely animals .
we'll see they start to behave like
animals and that's exactly what we see
in our society knife crime in london has
just gone off the map but it's because
people have been taught and you were
talking about abortion these killing
infants after birth that's Peter singers
view and I've debated him and the issue
stem straight from his atheism and so I
think we ought to be more upfront about
the connection between some of these
issues and the worldview of the society
around if I could just add on that
quickly you know I mentioned this
equality forum that the Democrats had
last night and one of the things that
that it seems to me that they're always
trying to outdo themselves and who can
be the most left or the most progressive
or the most collectivist and you may
have heard this last night but better
well Roarke basically said the churches
and places of worship that don't that
aren't for same-sex marriage he would
want them to lose their tax exemption
but that's an absolutely absurd position
but it this is why those of us we can
disagree on on these sort of margin
issues but we have to come together
around the freedom issue number one
because what
come next is that they'll say all right
well now if you're not completely
pro-choice you should lose your tax
exemption and they will just keep
encroaching on every set of beliefs you
have so I may not share that exact
belief with you but I would 100% defend
your ability to have that belief in the
place that you worship without question
foot one for you here John and and it's
keeping on a sort of pretty serious
attack as well this person asks on the
premise that we are created in the image
of God and we each have value how do you
respond to the growing rate of suicide
in the West I think we're seeing this
especially among men there the suicide
is increasing at an alarming rate what
where do you see that coming from um
where how do you speak to it as someone
who does believe people are made in the
image of God what what does suicide have
- what's the response eyespace -
somebody who goes that route this is
very complicated question because
suicides are all different I have a
colleague who's one of the world's
experts on suicide I'm just talking to
makes me realize that this is a very
complex thing but just thinking about it
simplistically people tend to commit
suicide when they have nothing to live
for
they've got no future that they can see
and I do believe that the Christian
message addresses that head-on by giving
people that and I have personally seen
people come from the edge of suicide and
become settled balanced everything else
because they've come to faith in Christ
and they've got that meaning that has
answered that need to destroy themselves
and the difficulty is I'm too old now to
really understand the vicious effect
that Facebook for example likes and
dislikes haven't
people where they get bullied in
cyberspace and they feel completely
awful and they lose all their self-worth
I mean the cruelty the people exhibit to
one another is unbelievable and and
what's the answer to that well the
answer to I've got to start with me
I love Jordans thing clean up your own
room before you clean up the world and
it needs to start with me the people I
know looking for the signs of depression
or feeling down or feeling lonely or
feeling meaningless we can all do a
little something it may not be much it
may not hit their headlines but it could
take someone back from the brink there's
no Universal answer to it there is a
follow-up question that this is part in
this yes
which is what about the case of
believing Christians who perhaps commit
suicide and I think that has been quite
a significant case here in Southern
California recently well I know of one
or two very significant cases of people
I actually knew and I'm not a doctor I'm
not a psychologist
but we've got to realize that our minds
can actually break down there used to be
a time fortunately it's past where
psychiatrists and psychologists were
looked upon by many in the Christian
community with a lot of suspicion if you
broke your leg you went to a doctor and
I was fine everybody thought that was
fine but if your mind broke that wasn't
fine and I think we've got to realize
that even to believing Christians are
still human they still have got flaws
and difficulties your temperament
doesn't change overnight you may have
noticed when you become a Christian and
if you haven't noticed that you ought to
wake up and notice a
and therefore we can break down the
chemical imbalance in our brain can go
and people jump off a cliff or shoot
themselves we need to be very careful
how we judge those people because we
don't see inside their mind and I want
to say okay this has happened it's
tragic but don't judge what was going on
in their mind you've got to leave it to
God ultimately
I would just add one thing to that
quickly which is there's a strange
paradox right now because we're more
connected than we've ever been right
well on Twitter and Facebook and YouTube
and all these things and we can connect
with people we can send pictures to
people and do all this stuff right and
it feels very connected and then on the
other hand them the number one type of
email that I get is people that are
afraid to say what they think and they
say they watch my show because they're
afraid to say what they think and I
happen to be having some of the
conversations that are the things that
they're thinking about and I suspect
that if you're walking around as most of
us do probably everyday not really
saying the things that you're thinking
and view the end result of that will be
such a disconnect from from reality
because all you've got then left is your
own mind and if you do that over and
over and over and over again
you got you got nothing left and I and I
suspect that would be the type of place
where there would be you could see
yourself having to make that horrific
choice because connected versus not
friendship yeah absolutely and we've
gone over some pretty big issues tonight
and and we've had many many more
questions in than we can answer there's
there's just one maybe which kind of
sums up the evening to some extent that
we've had which is question for for John
referring today which is John do you
want Dave to become a Christian
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I really have to ask my agent what the
original pitch was I I don't choose well
the questions to kind of choose
themselves are there so many people are
basically asking hey what can you ask
Dave this special about Christianity so
I hadn't I had very little choice in the
matter but yeah I mean I'm guessing the
answer is yes John dude we're not
guessing because I've experienced a life
which I don't deserve which has been
full of profound joy a journey that has
been deeply meaningful to me and it's
connected with my relationship with
Christ of course not only day but
everybody here because there may be many
skeptics here and people watching online
of course my desire is that they can
share that experience that I share and
become Christians but but I'm not in the
business of browbeating people and
forcing them beyond where they are I
feel very strongly and that's why I
believe in public discussion let's have
the discussion on the table from
different points of view but trust the
people to make up their own mind and so
my motivation is to get the message out
and leave the results with God but my
desire is that of course it's that but
don't specify Dave alone per job thank
you just think of our neighbors and our
friends
is it our desire I I think when I'm
asked a question like this I get very
slightly nervous
because I want to relate to people as
whole persons not just as evangelism
Father and that's very important
they've you have been a tremendous sport
tonight and I recognize that you've been
so gracious and willing to engage with
you know things actually occasionally
being browbeaten actually on this but I
guess you know if we come to just some
final thoughts at the end of our
conversation now what for you has been
the value of having a conversation like
this
what for you why do you sit down week in
and week out with people that you may
not necessarily agree with on everything
but you're you're interested in finding
stuff out from what what's the value of
these kind of big conversations around
culture faith and God in the end yeah
well first off it never struck me as so
obvious you know Jews don't try to
convert people that's made this doubly
funny for me yeah I think no this person
just joking aside this has been an
absolute pleasure you know I I have
found that when I am having an interview
with someone that is really real when
we're suddenly hitting some unchartered
territory or I can really see somebody
exploring a new idea or not giving me
the packaged answer and and we've really
connected in that deep way that I can
actually feel something and I really
mean that I can feel a physical reaction
to that that's sort of warm I can't
really fully describe it but but it's
not just something physical it's almost
like truly it's almost like I can see
it's almost like an aura around somebody
and it's so this is sort of a religious
something I guess I'm giving you but I
can feel something when something is
truly real and I think we all know those
moments when when you sort of let all of
the other stuff go and you're just
having something that's real there's
something there's something there
however you want to describe that I love
being on this type of adventure this
type of conversation this is exactly why
I do what I do because we desperately
need it you know there's been a I think
the theme throughout all of this beyond
the personal stuff to me but I think the
theme really was that there is a crisis
of meaning and we're all sort of
realizing that the world is in complete
flux right now the future feels like
it's in flux I'm 43 years old I was born
in 76 at no point in my life until the
last say two years
or three years did the world feel like
it was in flux like the future is
actually confused will America continue
to exist the way it exists well the
West's continue to exist the way it
exists the UK I mean you guys have all
sorts of crazy thing they've got
interesting adventures yes - yeah I mean
I could do an hour on breaks it well
that's more difficult than God so so
many people are feeling that though that
that sense of uncertainty and for the
final Jordan reference that I'll make
tonight I mean he was he was has been
trying to hand people a little bit of a
little bit of not a little bit some of
the tools to make the world a little
less uncertain because if you can if you
can hold yourself first then you can
deal with the rest of it right so this
is a this is an absolute absolute
pleasure and and I will gladly have you
both on my show we can we can do this
together or we could do it separately
and we can continue these conversations
and more than anything else what I would
say is you know for you guys here I
think there's a feeling out there that
you know if you listen to the way the
mainstream frames everything it's like
somehow you guys are the bad guys or
Christians or the bad guys or
conservatives are the bad guys and this
is just sort of factory setting boring
dribble I know it's not true because I'm
in this room with you right and I'm not
gonna get lynched on the way
[Applause]
right like we know that there's yeah
yeah I know I got it I got like a few
people answer that he thought getting
lynched okay we know that right and and
I think take confidence in that and and
you know start saying what you think
that that's all that I'm doing truly I'm
talking to people and interviewing
people but really all I'm really doing
is saying what I think and for some
reason in 2019 in the freest country in
the history of the world that's a
special thing I have no idea why well I
know why but I don't know why I don't
fear it
I just don't but I think if all of you
started saying what you think a little
bit more you might find out that the
people that are your neighbors and your
friends and even and your co-workers and
even your family members who you
disagree with politically you might
actually start changing them but you'll
never change them if you don't say what
you think so that would be my main
message
I I think that's a great place to draw
it to a close so let me first of all say
thank you to John thank you today for a
really amazing very open very honest
conversation tonight thank you all for
all of your interactions the questions
that came in sorry we can get to all of
them tonight I just want to say a big
thank you as well to Calvary Chapel
Costa Mesa who have hosted us can we
give a big round of applause if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell